[Music]
time then for the press preview it's our
first look at what is on tomorrow's
front pages taking a look at the
headlines tonight the guardians chief
political correspondent jessica elgat
and spectators deputy political editor
katie balls they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's have
a look at some of those front pages
before we speak to our guests starting
with the mirror telling the story of
tami prescott a terminally ill mother
who says energy bills mean she can't
afford to properly enjoy her final days
with her two young daughters
the eye has word that a next generation
kovid vaccine will be rolled out in the
autumn specifically designed to tackle
the damaging omicron variants
and in fact that's also the lead story
in tomorrow's times
from scotland the national carries a
poll which found that no matter who
becomes the next prime minister support
for independence will likely increase
but in the express liz trust pledges
that she'll fight to stop the breakup of
the union
the guardian hears whitefall civil
servants could strike after they learned
of plans to cut their payoffs in the
event they're made redundant
let's slide in the metro reporting on
the rape trial of manchester city
footballer benjamin mendy who denies the
charges against him
and that's also the main story for the
daily star
the daily telegraph says the royal navy
is planning to end its role in combating
the influx of illegal migrants crossing
the channel
according to the ft china has cut one of
its key lending rates in an attempt to
soften the economic blow of the pandemic
and don't forget you can scan the qr
code that you can see on screen join the
program check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them and jessica and katie
are with me a very good evening to you
nice to see you lots to talk about um
katie why don't we start with you
page four of the metro kyostama's energy
plan critics say
about time um gordon brown was giving
his thoughts wasn't he a few days ago
and there was
there were questions asked about why
zakir starmer was taking so long what
did you make of today's announcement
well i think what benefits kierstama is
ultimately as you point out gordon brown
the liberal democrats ed davey have
already been out of the blocks proposing
quite similar things to the labour
leader in terms of
freezing the energy price cap but the
tories have not come out of anything
so
you
can criticize what kirstar is uh you
know ultimately you don't really have
any direction from the government
because you have a prime minister and
chancellor you can't make decisions and
you also have tutorial contenders who
don't want to get into the details and i
think that does mean he looks on the
front foot at least compared to the
opposition
uh jessica this idea um kyocerma says uh
will bring down inflation by four
percent because it's for everybody it
doesn't matter how wealthy you are
everyone is going to benefit from this
is that a sensible policy
i think to a certain extent you know
there are obviously other things where
it's it's wiser to make sure it's better
targeted at the most vulnerable and and
and often the cost of giving help has
been you know directed through universal
credit or done through to council tax
bands in order to try and get it to the
people who need it i think the reality
is that you know a bill rise per year of
2000 to 3 000 pounds is ultimately
something is going to have a huge effect
on most people in the country there are
very few people who can really truly
afford without some knock-on effect um
to to take to be paying an extra 200 300
pounds a month just on their energy
bills that's going to affect you know
even they can afford to pay it it's
going to substantially affect their
spending and that can have big knock-on
effects on businesses they won't be
going out to eat they won't be saving up
to buy a new car they won't be saving up
to to for a deposit on a house um and so
therefore actually um because the crisis
is so broad
as the labour was saying today and and
in starman was saying in some of the
interviews today that it is right in
this instance to take a broader approach
yeah i mean uh a 4 200 pound price cap
expected by january clearly something uh
needs to be done um katie just looking
at the uh mirror mounting pressure for
price cap freeze pictures there of liz
truss and rishi sunak as well uh is
what's been announced today by secure
stamina going to put more pressure on
the two candidates
i think it does simply in the sense that
you now hear what labour will do and
that just begs the question well what
would the tories do given they are the
you know the people in government
and then i think if you're looking at
the specifics we know that liz trust was
talking about no handouts just a week
ago and into the financial times so
that position appears to have evolved
to a degree
now saying there would be some emergency
release but i think it does make it
harder for the two candidates to keep
going through the contest without giving
details we know that richie suenack
plans to set out figures after the price
cap is confirmed that's the 26th of
august but given that he seems to be
fairly far behind liz trust
ultimately i think it could be too
little too late for him to unveil his
policies that late in august and but it
will at least put pressure on liz trust
to set up what she might do in that
emergency budget she's been talking
about and besides the tax cut she's
already pledged
yeah front page of the mirror jessica
once again highlighting uh the concerns
that people uh have that things are
gonna get worse but also highlighting
the real issues that people are facing
at the moment interestingly lemire did
the same thing uh earlier today
highlighted one particular story one
story out of so many
yeah i mean some of the stories are
absolutely heartbreaking and the two of
the mps who i you know happened to be
speaking to today told me two different
stories one where uh was talking to a
local um uh fbu fire brigade uh union
official who said that they were very
worried that people would not put their
heating on but potentially start fires
in their homes to keep warm and all and
another one who was telling me about how
families were telling him in his
constituency they were sending their
children away to stay with their
grandparents because they couldn't
afford um to feed the whole family or to
or to keep the heating on enough for the
whole family and the this is this is the
thing about this is these are the
struggles that people are already having
because of the high costs of living
never mind if
prices continue to go up and i think
that's some of the things that people
have also been saying in a way about the
labor policy is that actually it stops
things getting worse but there are a lot
of people already in dire trouble even
with the even with the help the
government is already giving and and
potentially you need more help even than
the labor policy is offering in in terms
of targeted support for those who are
extremely vulnerable yeah i mean there
has been a criticism um katie hasn't it
that shakir's stamina's plan uh sounds
great on paper but it's only a
short-term plan it's only going to cover
the next six months what happens you
know come spring next year
well i think this is a problem
ultimately
it depends on the energy market and this
is something which is beyond any
domestic government's control
and you can't legislate for all the
factors that are pushing energy prices
so high
including the war in ukraine
and therefore
how do we know that things are going to
be better in six months time and i think
that looking at some of the things that
the institute for fiscal studies paul
johnson has said which is
you can talk about how which labour are
trying to push this idea that this is
good because it will you know stop
inflation hitting a certain figure
but that is just temporary at some point
that is going to get in the system
unless we are just you know for a
sustained period um keeping this in
place which would have a huge effect on
public finances and some lightning
yeah we still get struggling a bit with
your connection there um i think i think
what katie was leaving i think some
people watch it
yeah we're getting let's go to jessica
just for the just for the moment katie
because the line the line is breaking up
um i mean jessica uh martin lewis the
the money-saving expert is saying that
this crisis needs to be looked at in the
same way as the pandemic was looked at
it's it's as big as that in terms of
affecting people's lives
yeah and and actually when ed davey
launched his version of this that's what
he called that he called it an energy
furlough scheme because you know the
magnitude of the intervention is so much
and and that the the impact um you know
the shock waves that will be felt
through the through the whole of the
economy um because of these rising
prices are immense i mean even uh today
the bbc was running a story about a um a
a a place in glasgow a chinese
restaurant that had to close down
because it's a quarterly bills went from
about a thousand pounds
per quarter to ten thousand pounds and
there is you know small businesses just
can't sustain that and especially they
can't sustain it if people stop spending
money in their in their businesses
because they also have you know far
higher bills to pay so there there's so
just like covet this the energy price
crisis just hits so many different uh
parts of the economy um
and that's one of the reasons why i
think people see it as needing another
big intervention
okay well let's uh move on to
another issue still concerning money and
the difficulties that people are facing
it's on the front page of the
financial times we'll just try your line
again
katie tell us about this 50-year
fixed-rate mortgages
yes i think lots of people are currently
quite relieved that they've managed to
if you have managed to
fix your rate in the past six months and
given how high they're thought to
go this seems quite extreme version
which is fixing a mortgage for 50 years
and which they're pitching as a way to
tackle with inflation on these ideas of
course in doing that you can see some of
the appeal but i think personally you
would hope that within 50 years or at
least in that period things get a lot
less bad than they seem to be in the
immediate future
yeah i'm just having a look at the uh
the detail of this to see if you've got
any idea of what the interest rate would
be could offer rates of four to four and
a half percent on the 30 to 50 year
loans i mean it's quite it's quite a
gamble jessica isn't it um because you
know so that's quite a high interest
rate and you're stuck with it
yeah absolutely i mean those of us were
sort of lucky to fix a mortgage for
a you know
longest term when
when rates were were much lower than
that and but when you know over the
course of this of the 50-year period you
know who knows perhaps you do end up
like maybe it ends up averaging out
about that and i mean you hope that it
doesn't you hope it doesn't get an awful
lot higher but you know people in my uh
my parents generation remember paying
much much higher um interest rates than
that um on a mortgage so you know
potentially if you're if you're not the
gambling type and you like to know what
you're doing then it might be it might
be one one for you
okay uh we shall head to a break thank
you both for the moment chat again in a
minute coming up here on the press
preview we haven't really talked about
coving have we for a while but a new jab
could soon become a game changer we'll
explain why next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview katie and jessica are still with
us uh katie you've moved to another part
of the house let's hope the signal's bit
better the hair excellent excellent um
so some good news which is uh unusual at
the moment uh jessica the new omicron
jab that uh is coming out in the autumn
yeah and um the uk is the first um
country in the world to authorize uh
this jab
from modena and it means that millions
of people this uh this winter will get
um a jab that should um you know
specifically um target the omicron
variant and and other variants as well i
think um but uh we're we're still
waiting to see you know who exactly is
um going to be eligible for that booster
job and expecting it's going to be you
know is more likely to be those in the
more vulnerable uh categories um rather
than um you know all of us who got
a booster jabs um just as there were
those big rises before christmas
although you know obviously um there's a
chance that we could see a surge of
covert again in the winter it feels like
um we've got to a place now where the
where the nhs is is able to cope with
that even if even if we do see see
another surge i mean let's hope so uh
because katie we're gonna have enough to
contend with i think aren't we in the
autumn and the winter without another
serious covid wave
completely i think if you if you think
about all the winter pressures and that
we have coming up the track uh you would
hope this vaccine will just help to make
sure that covert isn't one of the major
ones because with the nhs backlog of how
tricky that is uh becoming to clear
um
and also just generally i think if you
think about just the the general
backdrop of this winter which would be
you know rising prices lots of people
struggling to heat their homes that will
have repercussions and it would be
really tricky to combine them with a
wave of the pandemic again so you hope
this is in the past and vaccines have
transformed the situation and therefore
news like this should be something that
helps to keep us in the place and not go
backwards yeah jessica do you feel that
we've had enough messaging from the
government about what the next stage is
what the next plan is when it comes to
boosters and autumn boosters and the
like
i mean understandably perhaps the
government's gone fairly quiet on on
on covid and on the programme but do you
think it's time that perhaps we did have
a bit more of an idea because of course
those boosters that we had are beginning
to wane
yeah and i think also the reality is
that people might have got you know this
might have been there the priority
messaging for sort of local health
services for gps and and that's and that
shifted somewhat because as people try
and deal with the backlog as as gps and
try to deal with you know
all the appointments that the extra
appointments that that people are making
and
and and the pressures that they're that
they're facing that you know it's not
it's not actually at the forefront of
all of the the public health messaging
you know for either from the government
or from the nhs and but that i mean that
is something you know when we're already
seeing what looks like a winter you know
sort of winter pressures on the nhs
carry on through the summer particularly
when it comes to ambulance ambulance
waiting times which which are under huge
pressures under across the the country
uh beds in a e then then you know added
to that covid surges is is
obviously going to be very unwelcome and
so um
it is probably um
i mean
you'd expect to see some of the
messaging around getting your booster um
you know ramped up in the in the coming
weeks especially because you know
inevitably there's probably going to be
some drop off in in take-up yeah and
katie i don't if you saw that that story
uh today reports that we've run out of
monkey pox vaccine i mean you know you
do you
you do worry slightly that um
we're not necessarily yeah we need to we
need to be on the case of this still
don't we
completely and we all saw i think
everyone was taken by surprise by covert
in many ways um even people who early on
thought this could be a problem i i
think it changed up you know for so many
uh you know diseases and scares
previously which didn't lead to that um
at all such a mass scale i think it was
a reminder of how these things can
escalate and how you do need clear
public health messaging um
and therefore i think monkey fox is one
example of this and also just knowing
who should be the priority when you need
to do things things like that are
important and i think with covid
specifically i think everyone's very
relieved we can live a much more normal
life now
lots of people return to the old habits
but in order to keep it that way i think
some public health messaging can go to
good use yeah okay um let's have a look
at the front of the guardian it's not
very often i say that it's a very
welcome sight seeing the rain people
with hep rollies up these are some women
in glasgow taking
cover from the rain as those storms came
even tonight really heavy rain here at
sky and it is it is good news
jessica yeah i think it is and it's
really hard you know it's really unusual
to be praising the rain coming in the
middle of august but we have seen such
an extraordinarily
um hot summer um you know with
temperatures getting so high
record-breaking temperatures
and and you know drought predicted for
for many months potentially
um you know into the
into the new year and you know the
rainfall i'm in east london the rainfall
here you know actually
didn't last very long at all it was uh
you know felt like going going out to do
a rain dance to make it last a bit
longer to to give the garden a bit of a
drink yeah i'm hoping we'll see some of
the footage of of the rain uh falling a
bit earlier on today we've got some
pictures from cornwall and also uh from
ireland but of course really heavy rain
katie is an issue because the ground is
so
baked that what we don't want is this
flash flooding
yes completely and
look i think given all the drought
warnings the fact there is water is seen
as a relief by lots of people who
wouldn't normally want it to rain in
august but as you say extremes of any
sort and weather are dangerous
and uh that is something we're gonna
have to watch out for i think it's also
an interesting one where lots of people
now being faced with you know the
prosperous hose pipe uh ban but also
seeing waterfall and and therefore does
that
occur their behavior when it comes to
following this guidance if they're
seeing things that they think goes
against it so there's all these things
to take involve on board when you're
trying to work out what to do
exactly okay katie jessica thank you
both